So we have been moving slowly up the OSI model layers and here we are at layer number 5 which has
you know is the session layer. And we're not going to spend too much time talking about the session layer because as its name implies, the whole purpose of the session layer is
of the session layer is to establish sessions, usually remote sessions. A perfect example of where the session layer has a part to play according to the OSI model layers is in VPN connections for example. So if you're connecting in using a VPN connection, as long as you put in the right credential information, your user ID, your password and possibly some other information like a one time password that is provided through a token.
It's ultimately the session layer that would establish that connection remotely. And one of the things that we have to remember here is that if you remember how TCP IP implements the OSI model, the top three layers, the session layer, the presentation layer and the application layer are all taken care of by the application within TCP IP.
So typically it could be an application that's running as part of TCP IP that ultimately does the responsibilities of the top three layers, including what you see here at the session layer.
So significant protocols for example that operated layer five that are typically driven through applications is for example net BIOS or RPC for example, these are remote applications that allow us to interface with certain things remotely like your VPN connections as we said before.
And what we need to remember is that this layer will only establish sessions or the way that companies typically implement this. For example, if you connect in using a VPN, ultimately that session will be established if you put in the right credential information, which means that some of those authentication protocols that we looked at earlier like pap, chap and EAP need to be implemented in order to provide that credential information that there is.
The remote person sitting behind that VPN is actually providing. And again, if the credential information is properly put in, then it's the session layer here that would ultimately establish that connection.
The next layer, layer number six is the presentation layer. And again, they've done a pretty good job of naming these layers for what they're actually responsible for.
The presentation layer is responsible for presentation aspect of things. So character conversions, graphics, compression, decompression, which is usually referred to as codex by most people is what's happening here at the presentation layer.
So there's not much here to worry about from a security perspective, except again, realizing that within TCP IP, it's usually the application that takes care of the top three layers, including this one.
So obviously, if you're doing things like compression, decompression, it's usually being handled by some application. And as you know, for example, codex are a hotbed of malware these days because there are really no standards in the industry for things like compression.
So a lot of the applications that require compression decompression out there will use their own. And that means that a lot of people out there that want to be able to access those services require the implementation of specialized compression and decompression utilities.
And unless we vet those and we test them, for example, in sandbox environments, we need to ensure that those things do not include a lot of malware and backdoor capabilities for attackers these days.
So those are the things that security has to focus on, especially related to things that are happening at the presentation layer.
Now at layer seven, the application layer, this is really the interface to the user and how it's provided through applications that drive, for example, what you and I do.
So for example, if you're sending an email, well, you're using some sort of email program like outlook, for example, which really provides the interface and the start into the OSI model and how it works to really allow communications to happen.
So here you have a whole bunch of different applications that provide specific functionality. In fact, a lot of the applications that work at the application layer are referred to as services and a service is really an application that has been written for a specific capability or to be able to do something very specific.
So we could talk weeks about specific services and applications that have exploits and vulnerabilities at layer seven, but we're not going to talk too much about that. We're going to summarize for you what it is that we have to focus on from a security perspective at layer seven.
And that is to understand that a lot of the services that operate at layer seven may be vulnerable because we've had the opportunity to understand the vulnerabilities that are associated with a lot of what's happening at layer seven as services.
So the idea is, and this is what we call hardening. Hardening is what most network people refer to the idea that if you don't need a specific service, you turn it off or you block it.
But if you need it, hardening also means that we find a more secure version of that application or service. And that's what you're seeing here on some of the slides that you're seeing up on your screen.
Like for example, HTTP is really the application or the language of the web, for example, but it really does not have any security built in and therefore it has a lot of vulnerabilities associated with it.
But if you need to use this, then you use a more secure version of it when you require security. And that's why we've got what's called HTTPS, for example, which really means we are taking the web traffic and tunneling it across a TLS or SSL tunnel, for example, so that we can add authentication and encryption.
Same thing with the next example that you see on your slide, FTP is considered to be one of the most vulnerable and dangerous services out there, but companies obviously require that.
It provides a very useful service. And so you can't just turn it off, although you would in those environments where you don't need it.
But if you do need to use FTP, then the idea is to use a more secure version of it. And of course, the industry has come up with exactly that and very appropriately, it's called secure FTP, for example.
And TFTP that you see there is really trivial and especially from a security perspective, it's pretty standard for all organizations to turn that off because it really does not have any security built in at all.
DNS, another example, DNS provides some very important services at layer seven, allows us to remember names that automatically get mapped to the IP addresses that allow us to connect to things like web servers and so on.
Again, very little security built into that. And so one of the focuses of network security for all organizations is to protect their DNS service.
And there is a initiative that you see there called DNS SEC, which is something that the industry has been working on, which just recently has become something that companies can actually implement to protect the entire DNS service.
And you've got other examples there that tell net, for example, if you ask a lot of network people what they consider to be the most vulnerable service, a lot of them would say tell net.
But again, it does provide a valuable service that we may have to protect. And so tunneling it across something like SSH would provide the security that may be required.
SMTP is a mail protocol. SNMP is something that's used by network people to remotely administer network devices. All of these may be useful.
But again, what we call hardening means that if you don't need any of these services, you turn them off. If you need them, you find a more secure version of them.
Or you at least use some of the latest versions, like in SNMP's case, they tell us that we need to use at least version three or later to address some of the vulnerabilities that previous versions would have had.
At layer seven, we also have, for example, gateways and gateways are simply connections between domains or networks that are provided again at layer seven.
And of course, firewalls can exist at layer seven, specifically they are referred to as application proxy firewalls, which most people would refer to as the ability to make the most informed and intelligent decisions.
Because again, we're at layer seven here, which provides a lot of functionality and intelligence. But we pay for it from a efficiency perspective.
But we'll discuss that later when we get into our firewall technologies and architectures discussion.